los familiares esperando Noticias al
frente de la morgue de Tegucigalpa este
miércoles las autoridades entregaron los
primeros cuerpos de las mujeres
fallecidas en el motín para el entierro
con sus familiares Bueno ya Se
realizaron 23 autopsias médico legal de
las cuales pues la mayoría ya fueron
retiradas por sus familiares siguen los
médicos forenses trabajando en lo que es
el proceso de las autopsias y en la
identificación científica todas estas 46
damas ingresaron al departamento de
patologías forense en calidad de
desconocidas Fueron identificadas por el
método científico de huellas 46 mujeres
fallecieron en medio de una jornada de
violencia entre las reclusas y en lo que
se convertiría en uno de los motines más
mortíferos del país centroamericano por
favor le pedimos a la autoridad que los
ayuden Andamos como cuatro familias que
no sabemos nada ya estamos desesperados
por favor ayúdennos si usted se fija
verdad en todo verdad Ahí no salió un
policía herido ni muerto entonces un
significado de que verdad
Yo pienso que ahí hay un complot porque
entre la policía y ellos hubo informes
de personas que fueron heridas con arma
de fuego pero la mayoría de las víctimas
fueron quemadas un hecho que tiene a las
autoridades en la difícil tarea de
identificar los cuerpos según los
informes integrantes de La Pandilla
barrio 18 irrumpieron en un bloque de
celdas dispararon a una reclusas y luego
prendieron Fuego lo que pone presión en
el país centroamericano en donde ocurrió
el peor desastre carcelario en un siglo
cuando en 2012 361 reclusos murieron en
un incendio en el que las hipótesis
arrojaron que posiblemente fue causado
por un fósforo un cigarro o alguna otra
llama en la prisión